why Big Brother so you you're an
Olympian you're an athlete
why Big Brother why not
no for real it's true it's amazing um
you know I want I'm always up for a
challenge I want to I want to do
something that takes me out of my
comfort zone and when this this show was
presented to me in my team I'm like heck
yeah like why not like this will be so
cool
on takes me out of my comfort zone and
it's a challenge have you seen the
previous celebrity version or are you
watching bits and pieces of it at least
I watched the first two episodes okay
last season's Celebrity Big Brother so I
guess I know the gist yes it and that's
all you have down is just the idea what
it's really about
yes in the first two episodes who do you
not want to be like from last season
[Music]
[Laughter]
Metta World Peace because he did not
know anything was going on okay like I
want to have some clue I'm like what's
going on okay and um I can't remember
her name she was the girl that was in
America hi yes yes I don't want to be
that because that's like a target
straight on your back okay so so he
didn't know anything and she just reads
she knew every yeah and you want to be
in the middle I want to just fly under
the radar really yes
okay there's I got some strategies I
want to hear about them all right my
strategies are well first of all I can't
cook
I don't know how okay so one of my
strategies you're self-aware
yeah so I'm gonna get with someone like
that can cook okay and I'm gonna help
them out be a helpful hand
who doesn't want self ahead yeah okay
shoot stuff okay and then I'm gonna just
become really nice to them and like to
the cook yes okay form an alliance epic
when they cook me food and I got an
alliance with them
Wow so you so you're looking for someone
to keep you safe and cook for you yes
Wow
that and being a athlete yeah like so
they think like I just I'm gonna eat I'm
gonna train and all that like everyday
but in the house they have this endless
pool where you can swim in place mm-hmm
and the only time you can use this
endless pool is from midnight to 6 a.m.
what does everyone else gonna be doing
sleeping I'm gonna be training so no one
everyone thinks like during the day then
I'm just gonna be like just sitting
around on the couch just not doing
anything so while they're sleeping well
obviously because you're me too tired
from staying up swimming all night so
you'll be just sitting around tired all
day really haven't I was working out and
like I guess like people that are really
like athletic it's like a threat because
they can win competition yeah but they
won't think that because I'm just you
know you're actually winning
competitions they'll still see you oh
there's another one
oh okay Wow so like I am an athlete so
like competitions will probably come
easier than for others okay easier for
me than others so I'm gonna not win all
the competitions okay so you're throw-in
athos over to the chef
yes okay there's my I'm catching on I'm
catching on I should have thought I've
actually played this game before
yeah and I don't know why I didn't align
myself to chef who was cooking for me
and winning for me like that would've
been great I should have took yeah
couple years ago that have been great
for me so not only are you going in
personalities I mean you're an athlete
you've been around all kinds of people
I'm assuming have you ever been locked
in a space with them where you can't
leave or escape them for a period of
time
kind of I mean for Olympians of like we
have the Olympic Village of where you
have roommates okay is kind of like your
buddy system yeah and you really don't
go anywhere without them okay so I mean
I've kind of
already know about that kind of stuff
just not completely ten different I know
a lot of differences buddy system is
going on here that you're gonna have to
I mean I think that's part of this part
of the game and it's part of the
challenge you're gonna have to adapt
like this I know so and it changes it
changes like this all the time you will
you seem adaptable you know what I mean
well I don't know the whole Chef and all
because if you're not adapting it to do
maybe a hairstylist or even maybe like
you know a realtor I don't know what
you're gonna do you seem pretty stuck on
that one yeah um when we're talking
about the Big Brother lingos cuz I know
you've been watching matured but you're
not you know I don't want you to know
too much like Shannon but you should
know something
yeah and last year a quiz the other
celebrities on there Big Brother
knowledge and their lingo something with
you
HOH what is that household POV oh well
okay p OB para veto you never heard of
that you know oh come on I mean if you
don't want the POV is gonna be okay back
door back door yeah I did hear about
that just like you put two pawns up and
then like you're gonna get them out but
you really don't at the end of the like
when elimination you switch it and you
know we I think you'll be okay yeah
because because you kind of got that one
okay you got that one and you got the
first one and you're a little bit off in
the POV Ella decide okay I think you're
ready alright I think I think you might
be ready for this um one more thing when
I was reading your bio I did something
alarming came across I saw that you
forgiving loyal and sensitive person
leave all that at the door now okay
don't don't go in there with that care
how good you can believe those people
don't know you the bath they'll backdoor
you well then I get backdoored
I rely that's that's me but um like
that's that's me that's my
characteristics that's who I am like I
know for this show I you know what you
do you can to the chef yes you loyal to
the chef to a certain extent because I'm
telling you and you're like well that to
me so I'm trying to I'm friend what just
yeah so you have a baby on the way yes
and the pregnant pregnant wife isn't
even with goes hand in hand and a little
baby and a baby at home
um how pregnant is she she's about 20
weeks so when I asked you why Big
Brother you lied because I had now I
know why you're getting away from the
pregnant wife and the baby you're on a
vacation you know my the hardest thing a
lot of people has asked me what's the
hardest thing gonna be about this show
and it's about not being able to say hi
Oh on a daily basis like I live for that
like coming home from morning practice
and having my son be I'm like daddy's
home yeah footsteps running oh and then
tackling me and giving me the biggest
hug and kiss and like that what keeps me
going on a daily basis and seeing my
wife and not being able to do that like
it's gonna be Sonny would say like hey
babe or how skatin doing Frank and she's
pregnant so it's like I'm just praying
every day that she's fine like ya don't
have anything to worry about
you know what Ryan's wife just so you
know I did read his bio and you were all
over it he loves you so don't so don't
listen to me he's not getting away
because of that
you